robert Hormats baltimore maryland it
shapes me apart because as I was growing
up when I was very young ballmer was
still a segregated City the schools were
segregated and it was only when I was in
primary school that they became
desegregated so I learned a lot about
social transition during that period and
I also was cognizant of the fact that
growing up in Baltimore I was really in
a relatively narrow social environment
so my parents fortunately were also
aware of that and they sent me to a camp
in the Poconos that was populated in
large measure by children of UN
diplomats and therefore at a very early
age I got to know people from all over
the world and I think that had an
influence on me and I also decided that
one side finished high school I wanted
to go somewhere else to school so I went
to school in Boston which further
broadened my social and economic and
political horizons as a young person I
was influenced by teachers particularly
teachers in my high school my parents
who like to travel they enjoy travel
they gave me and my sister a very strong
grounding in education we were
constantly told that you not only have
to study but you have to develop a
thirst for knowledge and they talked at
the dinner table about various current
events and various various issues and
made a real point of trying to encourage
us to read to inquire to expand beyond
their normal life to understand the
world and a lot of the issues that were
contemporary at the time I had a number
of things several things that went
through my mind at various points in
time one I was at one point interested
in medicine and still em although I
didn't pursue that my own goal was in
business
he encouraged me to go into business I
when I went to college began to take
courses in international politics
domestic politics international
economics domestic economic so over a
period of time I began to become more
aware of the world and more interested
in it and I think in the end it was the
opportunity to travel is the opportunity
to understand other cultures the
opportunity to see the world and all
that had to offer which caused me to go
into international economics and then
after school to worked in the National
Security Council for dr. Kissinger
hey